SECURE OUR SCHOOLS, AND TACKLE
THE DIFFICULT ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TODAY, AND A PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
THE LAST SCHOOL SHOOTING, WHERE
HE WAS REFERRING TO WHAT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO MOVING FORWARD.
AGAIN, THIS SCHOOL SHOOTING IN
SANTA FE, TEXAS, COMES AS YOU
LOOK AT THE MASS SHOOTING SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
THE LIST INCLUDES THREE OR MORE
VICTIMS KILLED, NOT
CONVENTIONALLY MOTIVATED CRIMES
OR KILLINGS IN PRIVATE HOMES.
BUT YOU NOW HAVE SANTA FE, TEXAS
AND AT TEN KILLED HERE.
WE HEARD FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY THAT THE EDUCATION
SECRETARY, BETSY DeVOS, HAS
HER SCHOOL SAFETY COMMISSION HAS
STOOD UP TODAY AND IT WILL MEET
FOR THE FIRST TIME NEXT WEEK.
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
LET'S START ON THE DAYS EVENTS.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
MATT SCHLAPP, AND NOEL ROTHMAN,
ASSOCIATE EDITOR OF COMMENTARY
MAGAZINE.
NO LUCK, LET'S START WITH YOU.
AND >> Noah: THEY HAVE BECOME
SO COMMON AT THIS POINT, THAT
CONSERVATIVES RESPOND BY TALKING
ABOUT CONSERVATIVE ISSUES AND
DEMOCRATS RESPOND BY ADDRESSING
GUNS.
THIS DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A WEAPONS
ISSUE.
WE SAW SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY SAY
THAT WE NEEDED TO TALK ABOUT
WEAPONS BUT THE PERPETRATOR THAT
WE KNOW AT A SAWED-OFF SHOTGUN
WHICH IS ILLEGAL.
AT THIS POINT, I THINK IT'S
PRETTY SAFE TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
A COPYCAT ISSUE HERE.
AND THAT IS A MEDIA ISSUE.
THERE IS ENOUGH SCHOLARLY
LITERATURE THAT SUGGESTS THAT
YOUNG STUDENTS ARE SEEKING TO
EMULATE THE HORRIBLE LEGACIES OF
PEOPLE LIKE THE COLUMBINE
SHOOTERS WHICH IS EVIDENT HERE,
WEARING A TRENCH COAT.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THAT POINT
AND THAT SOMETHING THAT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE KNOWS HOW TO
ADDRESS.
>> Bret: YES.
DAVID?
>> David: YOU PLAY THE CLIPS,
THREE MONTHS AGO HE SAID THE
SAME THING AS HE SAID TODAY, AND
IT'S SAD TO SAY BUT IN THREE OR
FOUR MONTHS NOW, WE WILL
PROBABLY BE IN THE SAME
SITUATION.
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF TEXAS
SUGGESTED TODAY, I HEARD IT, THE
PROBLEM WAS THE AMOUNT OF DOORS
AND THE SCHOOL.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH GUNS
BUT ENTRY POINTS AND IF THERE
WERE FEWER ENTRY POINTS IN THE
SCHOOL, THE SHOOTER COULD BE
STOPPED.
SO THERE IS NO AGREEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE BETWEEN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS AND I DON'T THINK WE
WILL SEE AN AGREEMENT UNTIL WE
HAVE A CHANGE, AND A PEOPLE OF
IN WASHINGTON.
>> Bret: MATT?
>> Matt: IT'S TIME TO GET
PRACTICAL AND THINK ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF STEPS WE COULD TAKE.
I DROP OFF FOUR OF MY KIDS AT
SCHOOL EVERY MORNING AND AN
OFF-DUTY POLICE OFFICER BRINGS
THE CAR IN FOR THE DROP OFF AND
I THINK THERE ARE TOO MANY
SCHOOLS THAT ARE VULNERABLE TO
ATTACK YOU.
WE HAVE THESE CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTIONS, QUESTIONS ABOUT
VIOLENCE IN SOCIETY.
I DON'T THINK THESE WILL GET
RESOLVED POLITICALLY BUT I KNOW
ONE THING WE COULD DO, WE CAN
HARDEN THESE SCHOOLS AND GET
REAL WITH THE FACT THAT THERE IS
VIOLENCE IN OUR SOCIETY AND
THERE IS A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE
THING IF WE DO NOTHING TO STOP
IT.
>> Bret: LET'S MOVE TO ANOTHER
TOPIC, WHICH IS THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE RUSSIAN PROBE LED BY SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER, AND RUDY
GIULIANI, THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY, HAS BEEN OUT TALKING
TO A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
NETWORKS HERE AT FOX, AND
OTHERS.
HERE HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, HOW HE WOULD TESTIFY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO
LIE, LET'S GET THAT STRAIGHT.
>> WHAT GIVES YOU THAT
CONFIDENCE?
>> I'VE GONE OVER THE WHOLE
THING, THERE'S NOTHING TO LIE
ABOUT.
>> Bret: THE QUESTION IS,
NOAH, ARE THEY SETTING UP
POTENTIALLY TO HAVE THE
PRESIDENT POTENTIALLY TALK TO
ROBERT MUELLER?
>> Noah: IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT,
APPARENTLY THERE IS SOME EFFORT
ON GOING.
MR. GIULIANI SPOKE WITH FOX NEWS
AND SAID THERE IS SOME
PREPARATION, ALMOST DEBATE PREP,
THAT THEY WILL BE RETURNING TO
THE AREA IN NEW JERSEY WHERE
THEY DID DEBATE PREP IN 2016 AND
THEY WILL WALK THE PRESIDENT
THROUGH.
APPARENTLY, THE PRESIDENT WILL
BE DEPOSED BY THE COUNCIL, WHICH
IS A FRAUD PROSPECT, BUT I DON'T
THINK THE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE
EVER EVIL HE DID IT.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME, WE
ARE WAITING FOR THIS
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT, AND
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF REPORTS
INCLUDING "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ABOUT THE FBI USING INFORMANTS
AT THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> THERE ARE REPORTS OF THAT BUT
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE INFORMANT
IS OR THE ACCURACY OF THE
REPORT, OR WHAT THE INFORMANT'S
GOAL WAS IF THERE WAS AN ACTUAL
INFORMANT.
LOTS OF QUESTIONS REMAIN AROUND
THAT.
ON THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
THOUGH, THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
THING THAT CAME OUT OF RUDY
GIULIANI'S MOUTH IS THAT MUELLER
SEEMS TO SAY THAT HE WILL NOT
INDICT THE PRESIDENT.
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE HE CAN INDICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO I THINK THE NEXT KEY THING TO
WATCH IN THE INVESTIGATION IS,
WHO IS IN HIS SITES?
IS IT A MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S FAMILY?
IS IT JARED KUSHNER?
COULD IT BE DONALD TRUMP JR.?
OR ARE ALL THE FISH ALREADY
FRIDAY?
I THINK THAT IS THE MAIN NEXT
QUESTION TO WATCH IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: MATT, AND THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATION IS ALSO ONE TO
WATCH.
>> Matt: EXACTLY.
THE PROBLEM FOR ROBERT MUELLER,
IF YOU LOOK AT HIS POLL NUMBERS,
THEY HAVE BEEN COMING DOWN AND
COMING DOWN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE LAWYER HE
HIRED HAD A POLITICAL AX TO
GRIND AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
SO I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME,
THERE ISN'T A DOWNSIDE TO THE
PRESIDENT AVOIDING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S TEAM.
I THINK THE SECOND THING IS --
YOU'VE SEEN JAMES CLAPPER ON CNN
TALKING ABOUT HOW IT WAS A GOOD
THING TO HAVE A SPY IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S THE MOST OUT -- AS THING
I'VE EVER HEARD OF AND I THINK
WE NEED A TOWER COMMISSION.
PICK THREE PEOPLE OF EMINENT
REPUTATION WHO UNDERSTAND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY THREATS, TO
USE IN THE NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE